this educational video series will focus  on cancer research and advancements for  2013 and is brought to you by lab roots  the leading professional networking  website designed to connect the  scientific world by leveraging a myriad  of unique features and helping users  discover meaningful collaborations  across geographic boundaries and fields  of expertise cancer is one of the most  prevalent and pervasive diseases in the  world but this year there have been some  amazing new discoveries and advances in  cancer research new information brought  about by studying how cancer originates  and groves helps researchers and  clinicians develop approaches for  diagnosis and treatment in addition to  prevention and research discoveries  there have been several advances in  cancer therapy this year these advances  are contributing to the rise in the  number of people who are surviving  longer and living fuller lives after  their cancer diagnosis